John Rambo has been fighting his battles on
the big screen for nearly four decades.
And now, we’re going to take a look at his
tale, from First Blood to Last Blood, and
explain his action-packed story.
What little we know of John Rambo's early
life is cobbled together from various references
he and other characters have made to it over
the course of the four films so far.
He grew up on his dad's horse ranch, then
was drafted into the U.S. Army at the age
of 18.
After nine months of training, he was deployed
to Vietnam, where he learned how to be really
good at killing, and how to tie a wicked headband.
Rambo became a Green Beret and continued working
in deep cover and reconnaissance missions
until he was captured by the Viet Cong after
an ambush and became a prisoner of war.
For the next several months, he was tortured
along with his comrades from Baker Team.
Fortunately, Rambo managed to escape the POW
camp.
He returned to military service, but the deep
trauma he'd suffered began to show through
in the form of a nervous breakdown, leading
to him eventually being honorably discharged.
In December 1981, Rambo traveled to Washington
State to visit Delmar Barry, a friend from
Baker Team, only to be told by Barry's family
that he'd died as a result of Agent Orange
exposure.
This made Rambo the last surviving member
of Baker Team.
"Baker team, they're all dead sir."
"Not Delmar Barry.
He made it."
"Barry's gone too sir."
Rambo moved on, and wandered into the nearby
town of Hope, where the local sheriff Will
Teasle tried to quickly usher him out of town
for fear that he'd cause trouble.
Rambo, who was just looking for something
to eat, went back into Hope anyway, leading
Teasle to arrest him.
Teasle's deputies began harassing and threatening
Rambo at the station.
Using his Green Beret skills, Rambo fought
his way out of the station before making his
getaway on a stolen motorcycle.
In the ensuing search, Teasle's deputy, Art
Galt, began firing at Rambo from a helicopter.
Rambo retaliated by hurling a rock at the
chopper.
As a result, the helicopter pilot lost control,
and Galt fell to his death.
Yeah, it was self-defense, but now he was
wanted for killing a cop.
Dismayed over the death of Galt, Rambo tried
to convince Teasle that it was accidental,
and he begged the sheriff for no more trouble.
Teasle, driven to rage by the loss of his
friend, continued the fight, as Rambo incapacitated
his deputies in the woods.
The National Guard arrived to help with the
search, and with them came Col. Trautman,
Rambo's former commanding officer.
"I didn't come here to rescue Rambo from you.
I came here to rescue you from him."
With the manhunt ramping up, the National
Guard troops went as far as blowing up an
abandoned mine to try to kill Rambo, but he
escaped into the town of Hope in pursuit of
Teasle.
Trautman intervened and tried to convince
Rambo to surrender Rambo causing Rambo to
break down in tears.
Weeping and grieving, the veteran poured out
all the horrors he'd experienced during and
after the war.
With Trautman's help, Rambo surrendered to
the authorities peacefully, and the great
warrior was ultimately sentenced to hard labor
in prison.
Rambo spent the next four years in prison,
but that all changed when Col. Trautman returned
and offered him a presidential pardon and
his freedom.
In exchange, Rambo would have to assist in
an operation to confirm reports of American
prisoners still being held in Vietnam, under
the supervision of Marshall Murdock.
Rambo reluctantly agreed to this, but the
mission was rocky from the start.
When Rambo spotted an American prisoner tied
up out in the open, he disobeyed orders and
rescued him.
In the ensuing battle, Rambo destroyed a Vietnamese
gunboat and asked for extraction by American
forces.
Murdock, fearing a scandal if the American
public found out about the remaining prisoners
being left in Vietnam, left Rambo to be captured
by the Vietnamese and their Russian allies.
Of course, Rambo ultimately escaped and freed
all the prisoners at the camp.
When he returned to the American base with
the POWs, Rambo immediately made for Murdock's
office and machine-gunned his entire command
center in classic Rambo fashion.
"AHHHHHHHH"
Then he went after Murdock, who'd left him
to die.
Trautman intervened and asked Rambo to walk
away and take his government pardon.
Rambo, once again feeling betrayed by his
country's treatment of its soldiers, spared
Murdock's life, but he didn't return to America.
Three years after things went crazy in Vietnam,
Col. Trautman tracked down Rambo, who was
living in a kind of self-imposed exile in
Thailand.
Trautman asked Rambo for help in a CIA mission
to provide aid to Afghan fighters battling
the Soviets.
Rambo declined, but when Trautman was captured
in Afghanistan, Rambo decided to embark on
a rescue mission.
He headed over to Afghanistan to infiltrate
the Soviet base where Trautman was being held.
He was able to rescue Trautman, but Soviet
Colonel Zaysen launched a pursuit, determined
to kill Rambo and Trautman both.
After commandeering a Soviet tank, Rambo killed
Zaysen in the world's most epic game of chicken.
With the battle won, Rambo and Trautman left
Afghanistan together, and Rambo ultimately
returned to isolation in Thailand.
Around 20 years passed after the incident
in Afghanistan, and during all that time,
John Rambo managed to maintain his quiet life
in Thailand, earning a small living by catching
and selling snakes and transporting people
on his boat.
But that all changed when a group of missionaries
from Colorado asked if he would take them
into Burma to provide humanitarian aid.
Rambo was reluctant.
“He’s like, ‘It’s a war zone up there.’”
But he agreed after one of the missionaries,
Sarah Miller, convinced him that they could
make a difference.
“And he’s like, ‘You bringin’ any
weapons?’”
Rambo dropped the missionaries off in Burma,
only to later be approached by their minister,
who informed them of their capture by government
soldiers amid a mass slaughter.
A big softie at heart, Rambo agreed to aide
a group of mercenaries hired by the church
to rescue the missionaries.
And obviously, things got super bloody.
In the middle of a fierce firefight, Rambo
pretty much single-handedly rescued the mercenaries
and the missionaries from essentially every
bad guy in Burma.
After rescuing Sarah, Rambo took her message
of kindness to heart, and he returned home
to Arizona to visit his father for the first
time in many years.
Rambo: Last Blood will pick up roughly a decade
after the events of Rambo, and while the film
hasn't been released yet, we do know a few
things about the plot.
Rambo seems to have stayed in Arizona, and
he's made at least some kind of peace with
his existence there.
Last Blood will feature Rambo's niece in peril
after she's abducted by a Mexican cartel.
In an effort to get her back at all costs,
Rambo will revisit his old combat skills one
last time, heading into Mexico to battle the
cartel.
We don't yet know exactly how that will unfold,
how much we'll learn about Rambo's home and
family life, or how well he's dealing with
his past trauma, but we do know two things
for sure.
First, Rambo: Last Blood will hit theaters
on September 20, 2019.
Second, there will definitely be some more
blood.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.